make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are picking back up again with
avengers new avengers right the collapse
of everything the death of all that
stuff and picking up from the last video
that we made
this one we pick up with the illuminati
right and this is
this is really cool because this kicks
off with the idea
of what the illuminati have been doing
right more so in terms of like expanding
their roster
and so on and so forth now for those of
you guys who recall uh the last video
that we did we talked about how amadeus
cho who's like the eighth smartest
person in the world
had become part of the illuminati and
their purpose was or at least his
purpose was to break
into basically the headquarters of
shield and to download some information
and get it to the get it to the
illuminati themselves
uh what we end up getting is kind of the
other half of that equation right in the
sense that the illuminati we're actually
contacting abideth cho talking with him
and what they've been doing for the last
eight months and what we end up finding
out is that during this eight month time
skip where we just jumped forward by
eight months
we had this situation where uh basically
the shield has constantly been after the
illuminati right and they've been
cutting them off at almost every single
angle and one of the things we end up
learning
here is they end up going low tech now
the cool thing about this is that
they're actually in a base of operations
right now uh this was introduced as part
of jonathan hickman's fantastic four run
and specifically was introduced under
the events of shield right his uh his
shield mini series which we can cover if
you guys are interested it doesn't
really pertain to any of what's going on
right now
but it does kind of give you the
background in terms of how shield came
into existence so invoking characters
like leonardo da vinci different things
like that let me know that's something
you guys are interested in seeing
but one of the things that's going on is
that the illuminati are also met by the
arrival of captain britain right brian
braddock and he makes this offhanded
remark that he's the last of the captain
britons and we'll actually find out how
far deep that goes here uh probably here
in a little while but
one of the things that he kind of
comments about is how the illuminati are
so advanced
and how it is that they're they're
moving how they're functioning in such a
way to where they're they're really
going solo tech right at the same time
like once amadeus cho gets the
information and downloaded of course we
saw in the last video that he was
essentially captured by shield right so
his signal immediately goes offline
this jumps next to day two and one of
the things that happens is that the
incredible hulk sort of comments to
captain britain where he asked the
question like man we're traveling so low
tech his response is because
shields tracking everywhere we go right
like we we could use those trans
locators where we teleport but shield
managed to hack the frequency and even
though they do hack it and even though
it takes them a couple hours to to
realize where we're at what it means is
that like if we teleport from one
location to the next we only really have
a couple hours in order to focus on what
it is that we're doing and while we can
do a lot within the span of two or three
hours we could do a lot more
in the span of a whole day right so
that's kind of what they're doing
they're also looking to sort of track
down name work but what they're doing
here is that in the aftermath of amadeus
cho being captured
they've basically created a device right
in the end and this is this is
sort of interesting you know it's
something that you don't really see all
that often in fact i don't really think
you've ever seen it before
but where they have these translocation
devices inside their hands and these can
be used for a lot of different purposes
one of the other things that it does is
it allows reed rigids to basically hack
the signal and then turn it into a
visual concept
meaning where you have like radio waves
emanating from from like this
device right it just literally sends out
a beacon sends out a radio wave and says
hey i'm here
i can teleport or do whatever i whatever
it is i need to do that they can ride
that frequency and in turn
watch everything that's going on it's a
pretty advanced bit of technology and
well beyond any real possibility i
imagine
but it does give us a scene where
amadeus cho is basically being
interrogated by shield and of course
he's met with the arrival of susan storm
now again
susan storm had turned against reed
right she turned against her husband and
one of the things that kind of goes on
we'll find a little more information
about this later on but she feels
betrayed by reed richards and that's why
she had essentially turned against him
but one of the things that happens here
is that you have amadeus cho kind of
being a little bit of a smart aleck and
it's it's it's sort of funny because
amadeus cho was in a lot of ways
depicted as a character
who kind of got carried away by his own
intelligence right in the sense that he
wasn't he wasn't like useless right it
wasn't like you know he just wouldn't
fight because he's like i'm too smart
for this it was one of these things
where
he is exceedingly smart and anybody he
thinks that's that's less intelligent
than him
uh is somebody just not worth paying
attention to or toying with and in fact
you do get this
amazing sort of scenario where you end
up having uh susan storm basically says
like i know a lot about you right like
we know all kinds of stuff about you
like we know you're one of the smartest
humans on the face of the planet like we
know that you tested and like the top
one percent of of all people who were
tested at least in terms of their of
their overall intelligence and the
response of amadeus cho is that's that
doesn't really matter
right that's that's totally irrelevant
right because if we if we extrapolate
this out then testing inside that one
percentile or whatever it is that still
means that there's 250 million people
out there who are as smart as me
that's not a good thing like that's
that's not okay that doesn't mean
anything it means there's 250 million
people who are as smart or smarter than
i am so to quantify me
in a percentage base is stupid because
i'm smarter than that right i'm smarter
than
almost anybody out there with the
exception of like you know reed richards
and
and uh the incredible hulk depending on
the circumstance tony stark you know
black panther different people like that
and and susan storm kind of gets
irritated here right she gets a little
flustered and that was always kind of
the nature of her character
not so much in the sense that she felt
stupid in comparison to somebody like
reed but the fact that when it came to
like some of the super smart people in
marvel comics they were always written
in this way where they had this tendency
to look at people who were less
intelligent than they were
and seem like they kind of have to uh
walk them through the process
of of making things make sense right
like i'll explain this to you but like
i'm gonna hold your hand i'm gonna
assume that there's nothing about this
that you could understand
and while we it was never really reed's
intention to make susan storm feel
stupid the result is that a lot of times
she did and dealing with somebody like
him
and then at the same time having
somebody like cho who's almost kind of
like this this physical embodiment of
how she felt whenever she was talking
with reed and felt you know not really
able to keep up
uh it kind of pisses her off and so she
basically tells them like time's running
out for the illuminati right i'm going
to catch
every single one of you i'm going to
catch you all there's nothing you can do
to stop me now the other
part of this is that the the information
that amadeus cho was tasked with
accessing and then downloading to the
illuminati were weapons designs by tony
stark and this is very important here
and the reason why is because you're
dealing with some pretty smart folks
right you're dealing with like bruce
banner uh you know professor hulk
whatever you want to call them you know
just the hulk professor it doesn't
really matter
you got beast of course who's really
really smart you got reed richards you
got these guys but the reality of this
is that despite their intelligence their
intelligence is usually in a particular
field
right reed richards is kind of the only
exception his intelligence is basically
kind of in everything right the guy
knows almost everything about everything
but beast uh the incredible hulk their
intelligence is in genetics right like
biology just understanding how the human
body works gene therapy different things
like that manipulating or i guess
controlling genes and and so on they're
not really weapons experts that was tony
stark tony stark was the weapons guy
tony stark was the guy who was inventing
technology and weapons
for a time that hadn't yet come right
that's that was basically his entire
idea and downloading all these
schematics there's there's there's
so many of them right there's all kinds
of weapons
that were developed by tony stark like
just a zillion different designs right
like 653
separate designs are what beast refers
to and not all of them are going to be
winners but it gives them a lot of
information that they can use to take on
the cabal
as well as to find a way to stop the
incursions the problem with this is that
in the middle of all of that they're
suddenly met by by t'challa right
they're suddenly met by black panther
who basically says like this is it like
i've got to come in fast i've got to
translocate and they're like no you
i mean if you do that shield is going to
be able to track us and he's like i have
no choice
right like like it's at the situation's
as bad as it's been like it's total
failure here in wakanda i gotta go right
and so he basically ends up teleporting
directly to them which as we saw in the
previous video
was the result of uh proxima midnight
and those guys basically invading uh
wakanda the necropolis and then taking
out black panther and so
as soon as he as soon as he translocates
in then the question is what happened
right
the the question of read is what
possibly happened that you had to
teleport back here so fast and the
response to black panther is the golden
city has fallen right wakanda is now
gone like there we
cannot go back to wakanda there's
nothing that we can do there and so what
it does is it jumps to shield right it
jumps to rome and we basically end up
having like this this package that's
being deployed right it's a highly
militaristic mission right it's just
like sending this package through and
what we end up finding out is that this
is hawkeye now here's the here's the
coolest thing about this
hawkeye is such an easy character to
overlook right he's such an easy
character to overlook and to dismiss and
and even
myself like i'm guilty of that like i'm
guilty of looking at
at hawkeye and just being like hey
shootseros like in the grand scheme of
people like matthew malloy the marquee
of death who cares about hawkeye and
that's kind of true
right like when you compare them to like
high-level reality warpers sure who's
anybody compared to those guys
but but the reason why hawkeye is so
cool is because hawkeye has
all kinds of prodigious training but the
other thing is when he fires he doesn't
miss
and if what you wanted to do was to
basically take out a handful of people
especially the illuminati right black
panther uh beast
the the incredible hulk reed richards
these guys hawkeye's the one you send in
hawkeye is the guy that you send in
there to neutralize all those forces the
problem is
as soon as he gets in there the entire
place appears to be abandoned and he
keeps referring to archangel right he
keeps talking to this guy
the guy who's basically running the show
and we end up finding out here the
person who's running the show
is captain america right is steve rogers
that that
steve rogers is now hunting down the
illuminati now
a little bit of filler here because a
lot of you guys who have never read this
or
or who are like brand new to marvel
comics are like why is he old
okay and why do you have sam wilson who
looks like captain america a bit of an
exposition here so
leading up to this particular story and
this is why you have uh the the
eight-month gap so you can kind of have
stories
involving characters that were basically
running you know coming up on their end
to the point where this this story
begins to pick up or at least this
portion of hickman's avengers and new
avengers begins to pick up what you had
was a captain america run by a guy named
rick remender and rick remender had an
amazing run it was it was incredibly
good uh but one of the things that he
did here is he had captain america fight
a villain called the nail who
siphoned off the super soldier serum
from captain america and what it did
is it forced steve rogers into being old
the reason why this was done
is so that steve rogers could basically
be moved out of the way for captain
america and replace with sam wilson to
become the new captain america now
whether or not you agree with this
doesn't really matter it's outside the
scope of this video but that was the
move that marvel made
and so that's why captain america is old
when you compound this with the fact
that steve rogers had remembered
everything that had gone on with the
illuminati then it all leads to this
moment right the fact that they had
wiped his memory of the incursions all
that kind of stuff he recollected all of
that during original sin you guys see
how all this stuff basically ties
together right how all these things that
happen
whether it's in marvel comics itself or
it's done by jonathan hickman earlier
how it all comes together and creates a
cohesive whole it's why he's so good at
writing and so when hawkeye basically
rings into captain america and says like
there's something here like there's
something down here that you need to
come and see
once shield forces get there and captain
america arrives there alongside maria
hill uh you end up having this this kind
of chess game being played
between the incredible hulk and beast
and this is probably
one of the best moments of the entire
story because dude they talk
so much trash it's absolutely amazing
right you've got like susan storm
you've got hawkeye you've got maria hill
and you've got you got steve rogers and
you got sam wilson down here
and the the message that they're playing
or at least this conversation keeps
repeating itself right it says i'm
beginning to think that we're going to
be playing this game for you know like
to the very end basically and it kind of
keeps repeating right there's a little
more to it but captain america picks up
two and two together and says okay so i
need to move so like he moves one of the
pieces
and then the entire simulation begins to
converse with him and it's nuts right
because
beast is just kind of sitting there like
cleaning his glasses and they're just
sort of taunting him you know and it's
like it's like man like you're probably
wondering how it is
that we're interacting with you right
like holograms are basically
predetermined pre-programmed sequences
right so you can create a hologram that
can do a thing
uh but you can't really create a
hologram that can react in the real time
but the reason why we can do that is
because
you're predictable because you're
captain america you're about as
predictable as the sunrise right that's
just the nature of who you are and if
you don't believe me
then let's go ahead and take a shot here
everybody here everybody out there in
the world
wants to believe they're special they
want to believe there's something unique
about them that
nobody else has but the reality is that
once you boil it down
people are basically just the same right
you study personalities long enough and
you come to the realization
everybody's all kind of the same person
now it is possible you know like like
beast says it is possible that you think
i'm being disingenuous
but would you be surprised to know that
there's a 95
chance that either clint sam or sub
director maria hill
is with you all three of them are there
there's an 80
chance that you brought all three and
then the incredible hulk's like i would
take those odds
and then he says and oh my stars there's
even a 60
chance that you asked susan storm to
come with you
you're predictable man now the question
is what does all this mean
steve like what does it mean that i can
within a percentile better than 50 that
i can predict
what you are going to do what it means
is that you really are predictable it
means you really are a super predictable
person you are predictable when we first
met you
you're still predictable we know what
you're gonna do before you do it and
it's important that you understand this
message steve because if you wanna catch
us
if you wanna pick up the illuminati you
wanna capture us you gotta start
thinking a little better than this
right you gotta start you gotta you
literally have to start thinking smarter
the downside to this
is you're not that smart so at the end
of the day you're really only ever just
going to be chasing us
you just haven't quite caught up to the
fact that that's all you're ever going
to do it's the greatest instance of
trash talk ever right they basically
said steve you're never
going to catch us because you're not
smart enough like it's this is the
coolest thing
because it's true it's 100 true captain
america is just
not smart enough to catch up to them
that's just the way that it is right and
so what you end up doing is picking back
up on the on the shield helicarrier
with steve rogers right once he gets
there and it's kind of you know susan
storm and and so on basically kind of
re-watching this whole thing where
terrax the tamer is part of the cabal
had basically shown up to the united
nations and what he and this is one of
the things
that's that's not really given in the
real moment is kind of given to us in
hindsight but he had shown up to the
united nations and he had basically said
the universe as you know it is ending
right like your universe is going to die
and there's nothing you can do to stop
it but there is something that we can do
you know we as the cabal can do this
right if you give us wakanda if you give
us the the necropolis
if you give us that country then we will
save your world and we will save your
universe but understand this the heroes
out there
the the iron man like iron man and and
you know reed richards are the fantastic
four and black panther all these people
all these folks that you call heroes
they knew
and they didn't tell you because they
didn't trust you with the truth but it's
time that you be trusted with this
information right
give us what we want and we will save
the day and that's how it was that the
forces of the black order that proxima
midnight and all those guys that's how
it was they got into wakanda they were
allowed to be there
right they were given sanction there by
the united nations they were told you
can have whatever you want just make
sure you save the day and then the cabal
just started doing what they were doing
best which was wiping out everything
that they could
find and so it's one of these things
where it all just really kind of seems
to be crumbling down right like
everything's falling apart
enter carol danvers and carol danvers
basically says okay so there's a couple
of residual mental imprints that the
these psychics were able to pick up but
really not much more than that we know
that like captain britain has joined
their joined their roster now
we know that uh that t'challa was there
for a brief amount of time but aside
from that we don't really know anything
else
captain america starts asking questions
like are there people that we can get to
our side can we get betsy braddock but
the response of carol danvers is you
know like psylocke is protected by the
ex nation she's protected by mutants we
can't just go there that's one of the
reasons why if we capture the illuminati
and we get a hold of beast we're gonna
have a problem because the x-men are
gonna wanna take him back
and deal with him on their own terms
they're not going to want to let us do
that and the response to steve is they
don't get that choice
right like he joined the illuminati he
made his choice he knew what he was
doing the x-men don't get to decide who
it is that is you know
that isn't is not put on trial for the
crimes that they commit that's not the
way this works if they have a problem
with it sorry about their luck we can go
to war again
right and like it won't be like last
time we'll win you know and so it's it's
it's kind of cool like it's it's
interesting to see like how extreme
captain america has become because he's
hell-bent on tracking down the
illuminati right it's the one thing he
wants to do more than anything else he
also ends up learning that like robert
decosta bought aim bought advanced idea
mechanics which sucks for for shield
even more
because with everything that's happened
shields abilities in terms of like their
authority the ability to tap
into like the world's intelligence
agencies has been curtailed by an insane
level they have just
just enough leash to like monitor other
countries but they can't really act
without getting some info or getting
approval from like their prime ministers
or whatever it is the days of shield
being able to just do what it needs to
do
in order to to serve its purpose are
gone right like they're the only thing
they have
you know real free reign over is the
united states and that's it and as long
as the illuminati are outside the us
it greatly hampers shields ability to
function it's one of the smartest moves
that they could have made but robert
decosta buying advanced idea mechanics
gives him a
wealth of technology and resources that
are equal to or way beyond what shield
currently has
and is in his current form where it's
handicapped right and so all that's
really being brought in here by carol
danvers it's just more bad news right
like
like
literally the illuminati's resources are
growing by the day like robert de casa's
not on our side he's working against us
or at least seems to be working for his
own goal he's got the resources of
advanced idea mechanics so there's
really not much we can do for him or do
do with him and those avengers out there
that decided not to side with you when
you dumped information about what the
illuminati were doing and actually
agreed with their cause
they've gone off the radar right like
they're they're gone black widow spider
woman jessica drew like we don't know
where they are like they're
they're off reservation like we have no
clue where they are they turned off
their transponder signals so like you've
basically created another civil war
within the superhuman community sure
they're not fighting each other but like
they're on separate causes and that's
what's happened here right when captain
america
revealed to the avengers that the the
collapse of the multiverse that like
what the illuminati were doing it split
the entirety of the superhero community
those individuals who agreed that what
the illuminati were doing were wrong
sided with captain america everybody
else either sided with the illuminati or
went their own way
right and so you it's it's it's kind of
nuts right like the entire community is
fractured what we end up doing here
is one of the greatest revelations in
the entirety of the story
right because you end up having susan
storm who's told by captain america like
let me talk to carol danvers right and
so ultimately susan storm ends up
leaving and he starts talking to carol
danvers and he says here's the thing
unless if you come back in here again in
this meeting
and you cannot give me any information
about the illuminati even if there's
nothing then don't come in here right
like the next time you come in here give
me something to report whether it's that
there's nothing to report or you have
some bit of information it doesn't
matter
but do not come in here empty-handed
again and so you end up picking up two
days later in this abandoned subway
tunnel and you've got susan storm and
she says you can come out now and the
person she's talking to
is reed richards like she's a spy she's
a spy for the illuminati
in captain america's camp it's a genius
maneuver like reid's like do you think
they bought it and she's like yeah
like she's like all i had to do was just
pitch some story about how i was tired
of feeling like i was you know less
intelligent than you and being left
hanging by you
every time you go off of one of your
campaigns you don't tell me what's going
on that i'm left in the dark all i had
to do was just tell them that i was
tired of it right because it's common
knowledge it's common knowledge that
reed will like gallivant off on some
adventure
and not tell susan storm what's going on
and she gets pissed about it right she
gets kind of angry about it so it makes
sense that like all she has to do is go
to captain america with that story and
in his desperation he'll believe it
right because
in times of desperation people believe
what they want to believe
and captain america wants to believe
that he's got people on his side even if
those numbers are dwindling by the day
and so it's it's it's awesome because
they have this sort of of moment right
where it's like i miss you like i miss
you so much you know and it's like yeah
you know we
asked about the kids and they say well i
mean they're they're good you know but
franklin like franklin feels like he
failed you like he feels like he failed
you and your efforts to try to stop the
incursion what that means
we'll find out later but it's another
thing where she says like valeria has a
message for you right like your daughter
valeria she wanted me to give you a
message but understand
she's our daughter reid and i love her
more than anything but know that like
valeria's not always right right like
she's like the third smartest person in
the world she's wildly intelligent but
she's not always right the reason that
matters is because the note that valeria
gave reed
is it basically shows that like the
future foundation right the kids the
smartest kids in the world that like
they were all working on a solution to
try to stop the incursions and reid
wanted them to work on it because
kids have a way of using their
imaginations in a way that adults simply
can't do and they can think of things
that adults would normally never think
of but despite
all of their resources this is important
to understand despite all of their
resources
despite everything that reed's done to
try to figure out a way to end the
incursions despite
everything that's happened the formation
of the illuminati and their their lack
of desire to destroy worlds black swan
originally told reed and all them
like there's no way for you to stop the
incursions but hoping against hope
reed believed that there is a way to
stop them the downside to this is that
the note valeria reads says
you can't win right but like it's time
to find out a way
to not lose now i know that seems a
little bit confusing but it's important
just because you don't win
doesn't mean you lose it doesn't mean
it's game over there's still a way for
the heroes to find a way out of this
whole thing the job of read is to find a
way to do that but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you